where do people find these jobs
reality here's the thing reality
positions you don't really start as a
story producer you've got to figure out
a way into the company
and it's one of the few writing and
creative
positions where it's still very much an
apprenticeship
you're going to learn by doing in a
lower position and you're going to work
your way up to that which is why a lot
of people come to me that are in their
40s
or 50s and saying well you know i've
been a writer for this i want to cross
over to reality television
no no it's very it's very rare you're
going to have to start at the bottom
there are some people who have been able
to cross over
very early in my career i worked with a
writer named steve rosenfield
steve had had some experience writing
for
jon stewart had written for the daily
show he was able to cross over fairly
easily
some scripted people lamar damon is
another guy who plays both sides of the
fence
he was the creator of bun heads for abc
but he vacillates back and forth between
reality and the other
but unless you are very successful
on the other side of the fence already
it's a difficult jump you don't really
come in in the middle you start at the
beginning
so let's take a hypothetical 41 year old
male
who's done some television sitcom
writing
comes in for an interview and he may
have to take that
lowest-run job how should that person
present themselves
well let me tell you it depends on the
type of show if you're doing something
that's very heavily formatted where that
person's comedy experience is useful
if i'm doing a show where i'm doing a
hidden camera prank show where we're
pranking your parents
that person is going to be very valuable
to that show because they have a sense
of humor
and they will figure out a way to work
with you
that is a good example of when you are
able to jump the fence
if you were 41 years old and you had no
experience whatsoever
that's when you're in a bit of a pickle
because you don't automatically by
virtue of being 41
have any advantage over someone who's 25
right
it's not an ageism thing it's just
experience is what experience is
so let's suppose it's a person that's a
little bit more seasoned
in their life and they're coming in for
an interview they know they're going to
have to take a lower position
what's their demeanor like in terms of
do they want to come in
incredibly humble or come in with oh i
know this too
what's their resume look like are they
even bringing a resume
what are some of the tips um if you're
brand new
in your mid-career or jumping from some
other career
into reality television again it's like
writing it's like anything else no one
owes you anything you don't get to start
in the middle because of your age
um your attitude coming in should always
be
and i don't care how experienced you are
actually if if it's me
if i were on a show and i were coming in
to interview as a co-executive producer
with the executive producer i have the
same demeanor i have i want you to have
a good show
i want to make sure i'm a good fit for
you let's talk about what i can do that
benefits you and how this is going to
work
television like anything else is
collaborative
uh i really discourage anyone who thinks
they're going to change the world
from the standpoint of being an auteur
television is not for you film is not
for you
unless you're financing it yourself
there are too many people putting up too
much money and too many people whose
jobs and livelihoods depend on this end
product
for you to be saying well it can't be
that way because i envision it this way
and i do run into people who work in
reality television
who are you know who might have come in
a bit late in the game who think that
they have an advantage because of their
age or having written something else
that are very set in how they believe
this is going to be done
and it ends up creating problems for
everybody and they don't end up lasting
at the companies
is it's all about being able to do these
things as a team
but you also have to be verbal when you
do have an idea
you can't just kind of roll with it you
can't just recede into the wallpaper
and just say okay okay i'll do it the
way you want it you have to be able to
present an idea
but you can't present an idea as if your
idea is the only possible out
so what's an interesting way to do that
what's a way to
say you know what i have just this idea
just maybe i could just run it by you
instead of now guys this is the way it's
supposed to be done i mean what what
what's wrong
let me give you let me give you an
example with with the impossible note
i have an executive who says maybe
we'd really we really want to see more
of this person
talking about this particular subject
and then being passionate about this
thing
in reality that person may have only
brought it up in one scene
there's nothing to set it up with the
only way you can do anything is with an
interview
so when you come back and you're
offering that idea or that solution you
could say well you know if i do an
interview bite here i can go back into
this other scene and talk about
something that's tangentially related to
it so at least it seems like it's
introduced earlier
so it's not so much of a shock and then
you don't feel like it's happening
that's a solution to a problem because
it's addressing the thing that's
bothering the person who's giving you
the note
you're trying to figure out how to work
with what it is you actually have
if i just said no it won't work because
we don't have any of that
that's not a solution if i'm not
offering a solution i'm not helping
if you can't offer solutions on a
regular basis from a story perspective
you shouldn't be in reality television
because just saying no i don't no i
can't i never say i've never said no
to a network now never is if a network
note comes in
i'll say i've reviewed it and i don't
have the material to support it
but maybe we can do x y or z or i've
reviewed it there is no way to
accomplish it or
this didn't happen this way i don't see
i don't really see a way out of it
it always comes it always comes back to
a discussion
you know it's i'm going to offer a
solution if i don't have a solution
then tough for us but at least i didn't
just reflexively
tell you no right so let's take that
same
41 year old guy and say that he does get
the job
and he's starting at the very sort of
bottom of the totem pole
how is he conducting himself on a daily
basis
while he's there i think there are
certain things that you need to do when
you start
especially if you're a little bit older
and that is to sort of declare
declare your intention which is i'm
really hoping to move into story
anything you guys have that could help
me out i mean
if you're 41 it's quite likely that you
might have a mentor who's 27
just get over it just get over it there
are people that come into this
business all the time i'm 43 some of the
best people i've worked with
are in their mid-20s because they have a
fresh perspective and they also were
raised on the stuff that i'm making
i wasn't raised on reality television i
came into it and learned as i went
so these are people who kind of you just
learn the language
from watching it and they have wonderful
ideas and
because it's collaborative i don't have
room to be prideful i just have
you know i'm there for the solution
again
i don't care if he's 41 i don't care if
he's 25. you have to put yourself in a
position of i'm here to learn
because i want to move up if you don't
mention
this is a bit of a tangent if you don't
you that you want to become a story
producer or that you have a long-term
goal
you can become really good at something
and then stay there
because no one knows you want to move up
if you treat the job like you're a
receptionist at a
car dealership and just come in and do a
good job and go home
no one's going to promote you you have
to you have to say
i want this how can i learn
from you or i just want to ask you a
question about this because i know
you're better at this than me or you've
done it longer than i have
come in with a spirit of wanting to
learn not as not a spirit of
entitlement or you know i've
i've read every book there is on
screenwriting so i know how to get us
out of this
you